welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Foss in Star Wars Episode one The
Phantom Menace while not a perfect film
actually does contain some some strokes
of genius to establish the dark origins
of the Skywalker saga so what let's
continue our Star Wars rewatch series
and would be a white episode one
definitely does deserve a legacy greater
than the Star Wars kid first the title
the phantom minutes like may Star Wars
films the title contains multiple
meanings
while Darth Maul is certainly a tanta
Menace so is Anakin Skywalker so it was
Padme look at 22nd but more than anyone
the Phantom Menace of this film is cheap
Palpatine aka Darth Sidious the entire
plot is a conspiracy by Palpatine to
ascend it to power and if the storylines
of this film ever come off as messy or
over political just imagine the
Emperor's voice croaking from behind it
all according to any frustration we feel
is really the emperor telling us to get
into a gap because the dramatic irony is
alerting to us where this is all going
and often times we want to scream at the
screen stop don't do it in this whole
sense of foreboding is expressed in the
opening lines I have a bad feeling about
this
George Lucas gives the Star Wars
catchphrase to a young obi-wan Kenobi
played by you and McGregor who's
actually the nephew of Denis Lawson who
plays legend Tilly's Lucas's original
vision for the prequels was to focus on
obi-wan but he's shifted it to focus
more significantly on Anakin Skywalker
Lucas structures the prequels as a kind
of Shakespearean tragedy Vanagon being
the tragic hero kind of like macbeth
obi-wan is the Macduff righteous rival
figure and the Emperor you could say
it's kind of a lady macbeth figure the
true crypt of evil also interesting is
the response of Obi Wan's master qui-gon
jinn played by Liam Neeson I don't sense
anything
why gods numbness exposes his general
blindness to what's going on as we learn
an attack of the clones all the Jedi are
waning and empower and their ability to
see what is coming
qui-gon jinn represents the old order
that begins to collapse and die off in
this film a blissfully optimistic era
that comes off as shallow - those are
more familiar with Star Wars is a more
cynical broken world - the original
trilogy Lucasfilm artist Doug Schoen
stated that George Lucas intended
Episode one to be quote like a period
piece since it was the history leading
up to a new hope and like figures and
historical films we are meant to judge
these heroes
the past for that blindness Lucas's
strongest suit in the prequels is world
building including the Jedi traditions
that an older obi-wan wax poetic about
in a new hope an elegant weapon for a
more civilized age over a thousand
generations the Jedi Knights were the
guardians of peace of justice before the
dark time so it's kind of cool to
explore what this old man meant by a
more civilized age I can see how it'll
be one where's a Padawan grade when a
master feels that his apprentices reach
proper maturity he must face a series of
trials and if completed he cuts off the
braid with his lightsaber so the Jedi
here survived the attack by the Trade
Federation named audience and their
battle droids Lucas described these as
predecessors to the stormtroopers and
they were given elongated features
inspired by tribal African art
Palpatine's role as puppet master is
established early on and John Williams's
music identifies Sidious as the same
emperor from the original trilogy by
using the emperor theme to accelerate
our plans begin landing ruptures
remember this music because it comes
back in the coolest way we meet Queen
Amidala of Naboo played by Natalie
Portman and Keira Knightley swapping
identities between the Queen and her
handmaiden Padme in order to protect the
Queen so in essence Padme is also
playing the same masquerade game of
Palpatine making her a Phantom Menace in
her own respect they digitally lowered
Portman's voice to make it
indistinguishable from Knightley's
making it a challenge to decipher which
is which scene the scene similarly
shortly after this Senator Palpatine
transponder interference briefly lowers
his voice as well I have assurances from
the Chancellor his ambassadors in Iraq
so like Amidala's modulation he - sounds
like his alter-ego briefly and as the
Jedi are later blindsided by Padme
deception so - are they blind sided by
Palpatine's Sofia Coppola cameos is
another handmaiden actually there's a
lot of celebrity kids cameo in' in this
movie randomly and we're gonna skip them
because nepotism isn't Kraft I'm
interested in obi-wan equai GaN meet Jar
Jar Binks played by Ahmed best who
originally wore a prosthetic suit before
his movement was later mapped over with
CGI according to The Phantom Menace
making of documentary which is
fascinating Lucas gambled hard on Jar
Jar being the fan favorite of this film
Jar Jar is a key to Louis because he's a
funnier character than movies well know
but before I continue think you dude the
ridge for sponsoring this episode
the ridge makes everyday goods to a
standard you don't see every day they
streamline your life by turning the
things you carry like backpacks chargers
and wallets into tools for a better
living their flagship product the ridge
wallet was launched on Kickstarter in
2013 and now sits in the front pockets
of over half million men and women of
which I am one my old wallet was over
stuff with like old expired gift cards
and doodles I draw a napkin said it
couldn't bring myself to throw away cuz
that x1 won't stick no more the ridge
has helped me trim down stick to the
essentials and made me in general less
lumpy this is their aluminum wallets in
the raw color and they have other colors
including some very flashy Tiki designs
it's light it's strong and it's a cool
industrial chic vibe and pretty sure
industrial chic just means like sexy
robot this feels like a sexy robot the
ridge is a minimal front pocket wallet
that is designed to streamline what you
carry every day
it has over 30,000 five-star reviews and
is a better way to carry your cash and
cards there's a lifetime warranty if you
love it and free returns if you don't it
comes in titanium carbon fiber aluminum
and over a dozen different styles and
colors we also got their weather proof
commuter backpack that comes with a
shock resistant laptop holder in a
hidden RFID blocking pocket get a 10%
off today with free worldwide shipping
and returns by going to Ridge comm slash
new rock stars its Ridge comm slash new
rock stars music ode rock stars find a
link in the video's description below
after visiting the Gungan City they're
pursued by an OPC killer Cola crawfish
Sando aqua monster I love this line
because if you think about it it's a
simpler version of the rule of two
behind every threat is a second larger
threat lurking in the shadows they
rescued the Queen and escaped on her
starship
qui gonn will later identify as a
European model Jade three to seven three
to seven was the name of the Death Star
landing Bay where Han landed the Falcon
and the landing platform Cloud City in
Empire they escaped the blockade thanks
to r2d2 who gets a royal freakin
commendation for a droid yet still no
medal for Chewie they stopped at
Tatooine to replace their hyperdrive
venturing to the city of moss ESPA where
they meet Watto voiced by andy seecombe
Watteau often flies instead of walking
because if you look closely one of his
feet is longer than the other and we
meet Anakin Skywalker played here by
Jake Lloyd now the character was written
to be 12 originally but Lucas aged him
down so that his separation from his
mother would affect him more in the
later films much of Anakin's descent can
be traced back to mommy issues with
Anakin's vengeful rage on the Tusken
Raiders a key morale break for his
character Shmi warns him about this same
back
this line is another example of how past
history can be a dangerous burden like
cweigand obsession with ancient
prophecies the world we leave behind
we're not careful can distract and
corrupt us and again assets Padme if
she's an angel mentioning hearing about
angels from the moons of iego in a Clone
Wars animated series episode Anakin and
obi-wan actually traveled to iego and
encounter one of these angels and we
learned that Anakin built the protocol
droids c-3po still without his plating
here actually in the background of the
shop you can see another protocol droid
with its like missing a nod to c-3po and
a new hope and is swapped out silver leg
water also contains an EBA pod from 2001
a Space Odyssey inside Anakin's room
there's this statue that many have since
said resembles Maz Kanata from the new
films what's weird is the Phantom Menace
visual dictionary lists this statue as
being in Palpatine's quarters now it is
believed that Anakin's virgin birth was
actually Palpatine manipulating
midi-chlorians to conceive anakin in
Schmid's womb also Maz Kanata is said to
be a thousand years old and she later
shows up possessing Anakin's lightsaber
and the podrace flags decorate maz
kanata's place so I don't know perhaps
there's a connection between Papa teen
Shmi Anakin Maz and this statue a total
conspiracy episode that I hope to do one
day Jar Jar almost gets wrecked by
Sebulba whom Lucas based on a spider
orangutan sloth and a camel one of the
background characters at this cafe the
home at the yellow paint overs nose
actually inspired expanded universe
writers to create the character Quinlan
vos no motion on course aunt Sidious
chats with Darth Maul played by Rey Park
and voiced by Peter Serafinowicz mauls
appearance was designed to reflect
Christian art depictions of the devil a
one-point news designed a feathers on
his head but they were placed with horns
they used were shacks tile ink blots for
the tattoos at last we will reveal
ourselves to the Jedi
what does he mean by revenge here cuz
they never really say in this film it
turns out a thousand years before the
Sith were a group of Jedi who challenged
the old doctrine of restraint instead
believing that rage is a way to harness
the forces power which led to their
exile from the Jedi and their attempts
over the centuries to overturn the Jedi
Order
Anakin prepares for the PATA race with
his buddies would include Zack and Eli
Warwick Davis as Rodian
named weasel who in a deleted scene
taunted a young grito for brawling with
Anakin Davis also cameos as whatõs
friend walled in a later scene qui-gon
and Watteau roll a dice colored red and
blue who connected into the recurring
red vs. blue imagery throughout the
series in this scene Anakin is
associated with blue goodness but as the
trilogy goes on he'll be more and more
associated with red and black the colors
of evil according to the script this
cube was actually rigged to land on red
which is why water later tells qui-gon
that it wasn't a fair bet that we can't
admit why he knows that presiding over
the podrace is Jabba the Hutt and a
younger bid fortuna also a slave girl
wearing these same kind of metal bikini
that Leia would wear there's also the
female gardulla the Hutt the one that
used to own Anakin and Shmi and to start
this race Jabba bites the head off a
frog and spits it at a gong a callback
to him eating those frogs and returned
the Jedi this podrace is one of the best
sequences of the film the effects are
great it's super exciting and the way
they accomplished it is by basing it on
one of the most exciting sequences in
all of film the chariot race have been
her you may also notice how this
stadium's architecture is based on the
Roman designs of the early Christian era
when Ben Hur takes place also cameo in
during his pod race is this bounty
hunter or a Singh who would go on to
play a larger role in the Clone Wars
animated series and get a shout out and
solo after the race when qui-gon settles
up with mato
notice passing behind him is a broom
droid one of the ones that Maul sent out
and searched for them in a deleted scene
qui-gon finally notices this thing it
cuts it down after a brush with Darth
Maul they head to Coruscant as they
arrive you can see charger in the
background waving his hand in front of a
guard like you know those annoying
tourists in England in front of the
Queen's Guard also later in the
background of this city planet he can
spot a spinner from Blade Runner and the
Starship Enterprise from Star Trek and
they meet then Senator Palpatine there
is no civility and new politics
Republic is not what it once was
notice how Palpatine sentence structure
of there is no civility there's only
politics is a corruption of the part of
the Jedi Code which states there is no
fear only calm there's no death there's
only the force also in the back of this
office they included a prop of The
Maltese Falcon from the classic film
noir film a symbol of Palpatine's moral
ambiguity and they take Anakin to the
Jedi Council now in the 1999 release
Yoda was a puppet reconstructed to make
Yoda try to appear younger but the shade
of green was off so in 2011 George Lucas
replaced him with the cgi redesigned
that they started using the attack of
the clones also among the council are
samuel l jackson as mace windu whose
name comes from George Lucas's original
name for the mentor figure of his first
draft for the first film also there are
Jedi Masters like cloak une ki-adi-mundi
and yea tall a female of Yoda's mystery
species the Senate delegations include
wookies from Kashyyyk a twilight senator
and a few aliens from et with George
Lucas returning the nod to Spielberg for
the Yoda cameo in ET actually in the
Star Wars novel cloak of deception these
beans are described from being from the
planet brodo a Sookie represented by
senator greed leaps which is Spielberg
spelled backwards after convincing the
Queen to call for a vote of no
confidence on the previous Chancellor
valorum
Palpatine gets nominated on a wave of
sympathy for Naboo and now that
everything's falling into place
notice that when the Queen leaves the
slightest half smile begins to form on
Palpatine space Yoda in the council
reject Anakin fear leads to anger anger
leads to hate hate leads to suffering
but qui-gon defies them and explains
midi-chlorians to Anakin midi-chlorians
are a microscopic life-form that resides
within all living cells without dominica
laureen's life cannot exist he would
have no knowledge of the force
now perhaps when he listened to this the
meta chlorines in your blood boil yes by
giving the force a scientific basis
Lucas D mythologized what was once a
spiritual aspect of his fantasy world
into a kata fide science fiction one it
actually makes Star Wars a different
genre but as we re watch The Phantom
Menace these kind of facts were inserted
into this period film with the
understanding that this whole belief
system would be wiped away the same way
that in our world culture in science are
lost when civilizations collapse from
war
you don't have to like midi-chlorians at
all because in a few years this truth
will be replaced by a belief system that
used the whole Jedi religion itself as a
myth back on Naboo the Gungans engaged
with the battle droids on the plains
battle droids that for some reason need
binoculars you think that would just be
designed in his eyepieces and later in
the battleship controlling them gets
destroyed from a lucky trigger pool by
Anakin Skywalker the one Jar Jar knocks
over is numbered 1-1 3-8 for Lucas's
past film every single one of these day
moves as thx 1-1 3-8 in it qui-gon and
obi-wan engaged Darth Maul who reveals a
double bladed lightsaber this is boy
this design was actually borrowed from
the conex series tales of the jedi the
fifth war and this really duel was
designed by stunt coordinator Nick
Gillard who built out Barry's lightsaber
duel forms based on kendo in kim junsu
styles and we're hearing john williams
epic dueled the fates it's composed of
chanted lyrics from an archaic Welsh
poem called battle of the trees it's all
been translated into sanskrit taking the
verse under the tongue roots a fight
most dread and another raging behind in
the head and rearranging the sanskrit
translation into the core mata syllables
that were familiar with obi-wan watched
his his mentor die screaming
[Music]
just like Luke will do when he watches
him die we'll see Anakin will do both
when he believes Luke has died
and when he thinks Luke is about to die
and of course this Luke will say when
his soul died
it's a saga of nose if we wanna incept
defeating malls slicing him in half fun
facts at Mall never blinks once
throughout the whole film except the
moment obi-wan bites ex em now of course
the Clone Wars animated series reveals
that Maul survives this moment setting
him up for a future comeback in solo and
perhaps future live-action installments
qui gonn leaves obi-wan with a dying
wish to train the boy a lesson to never
ever ever feel beholden to honor a dying
man's wishes when obi-wan counsels Luke
is a force ghost Luke ignores his
counsel and that serves them well if you
think about it its major theme
throughout these Star Wars films the
world is for the living to decide what
to do with it ghosts and dying men
they're stubborn and biased they don't
get a vote
but Yoda reluctantly approves leading
him in mace windu introducing the rule
of two always two there are no more no
less a master and an apprentice but
which was destroyed the master or the
apprentice has he discusses I love that
Palpatine attends this you knurl the
balls on this guy to hide in plain sight
and to keep a straight face in a sacred
ceremony for a religion that heed to
tests now the final scene is kind of a
bizarre celebration
well not bizarre because of nabu's
victory but bizarre because the dramatic
irony tells us that we are witnessing
act 1 of e3 a tragedy this should be a
dark moment but here's a secret Phantom
Menace is and Dean is actually one of
the darkest moments of the franchise
notice here that Padme is dressed as an
angel the voguing the angel the moons of
iego that Anakin spoke of before but
also her premature departure from this
world and if you stick around through
the credits you hear a rendition of
Imperial March and the sound of Darth
Vader's breathing
[Music]
but here is my favorite hidden detail in
the Phantom Menace in the parade music
here john williams made a terrifying
easter egg
listen to the melody of the children's
voices singing sounds nice huh well
williams actually came up with this
melody by creating a major key a happy
version of the classic emperor's theme
from Return of the Jedi
and that theme is sung by deep male
voices that the pre music is a boys
choir it's a chilling reminder of the
dark destiny to come how the innocent
boy of this film will one day become a
cruel man with an iconic deep voice
serving the true victor of this moment
the film's true Phantom Menace do you
think the Phantom Menace deserves its
status as the worst reviewed Star Wars
film comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at ei boss and subscribe to our
podcast feed WikiLeaks for all of your
Star Wars analysis and keep an eye out
for our upcoming read watches of attack
of the clones and Revenge of the Sith
thanks for joining me
[Music]